[Música]
el gobierno de Haití pidió el despliegue
inmediato de una Fuerza Armada
especializada para intentar evitar una
crisis humanitaria a gran escala además
de la violencia a manos de las pandillas
el país más pobre de la región se
enfrenta un nuevo brote de cólera la
crisis en Haití fue tema de la asamblea
52 de la oea en Perú
Argentina superó la segunda revisión de
las metas Fiscales pactadas con el fondo
monetario internacional el organismo
aseguró que las metas se cumplieron y
saludó las acciones decisivas del nuevo
equipo económico del gobierno se
autoriza así un nuevo desembolso de
3.800 millones de dólares
Y ya comenzó en Brasil la campaña para
la segunda vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales que tendrá lugar el
próximo 30 de octubre en este inicio
ambos candidatos siguieron con su
campaña de acusaciones cruzadas mientras
que una nueva encuesta da una ventaja de
5 puntos a Lula da Silva sobre bolsonaro
Bienvenidos a este nuevo informativo de
France 24 dedicado a las principales
noticias del continente americano sí
Rodrigo sedano y es un gusto
acompañarlos abrimos este Informativo en
Haití porque en medio de lo que el
gobierno ha calificado como una crisis
humanitaria las autoridades han
solicitado ayuda internacional con el
despliegue inmediato de una Fuerza
Armada especializada El Ejecutivo del
Primer Ministro Ariel enriu Busca paliar
una crisis múltiple con un empeoramiento
del clima de seguridad y un nuevo brote
de cólera que amenaza a la población
anteriormente hablamos Con Edison damas
miembro del comité democrático haitiano
en Argentina que no se hablaba del
llamado general que hace el gobierno y
que podría terminar con más tropas de la
ONU en el país
le piden de manera general a la
comunidad internacional para mandar
tropas hoy en día lo que de las
informaciones que fuimos de cauda
recibiendo que están pidiendo
tropas directamente a Estados Unidos
Canadá principalmente y después para
llegar a una misión como de la ONU como
lo que fue la ministra y durante 14 años
que no ha servido para nada porque
después de todo el tiempo que pasó en
esta en Haití estamos a este nivel Hoy
entonces tratan de no decir a la ONU de
mandar tropas de nuevo entonces hacen
una llamada general pero esta cámara de
ayuda internacional de tropas militares
de manera general es ya sabemos por
experiencia que va a terminar siendo
tropas de la ONU de Los cascos azules
para estabilizar lo que tenían 14 años
para hacer y no lo han hecho y ahora
quieren volver a ponerlos de nuevo en el
país nos vamos ahora hasta Venezuela
porque la ONU aprobó la extensión por
dos años de la misión internacional
independiente que Investiga violaciones
de Derechos Humanos en el país sin
embargo el gobierno de Nicolás un futuro
rechazó la propuesta por tildar a la
misión como injerencista mecanismo de
monitoreo contra el país y afirmó que la
decisión la tomó un pequeño grupo de
Estados dirigidos por Estados Unidos y
nos vamos hasta Lima con las novedades
de la última jornada de la asamblea de
la Organización de Estados Americanos
uno de los temas centrales fue el
reclamo argentino de soberanía sobre las
Islas malvinas un tema sobre el que la
oea se hizo eco y aprobó una resolución
que defiende los legítimos derechos de
Argentina sobre las Islas y apoyo el
pedido de una solución pacífica y
negociada a la disputa que mantiene el
país sudamericano y Reino Unido sobre el
archipiélago
que quede claramente
explicitado que el Perú ratifica estos
derechos estos derechos de disputa
territorial de las Islas malvinas y las
Islas sandwich del sur y georgias del
sur y los espacios marítimos
circundantes seguimos con más noticias
relacionadas con Argentina porque el
país superó la segunda revisión de la
meta fiscal y de la acumulación de
reservas comprometidas con el fondo
monetario internacional esto le da
acceso al país a un desembolso de 3.800
millones de dólares en un guiño a las
recientes medidas adoptadas por el
ministro de economía Sergio massa que el
organismo consideró determinantes para
permitir una estabilización de los
mercados en marzo Argentina y el fondo
monetario sellaron el llamado programa
de facilidades extendidas para
refinanciar una deuda de 45.000 millones
de dólares las metas establecidas en
dicho pacto deben ser revisadas tres
meses
al completar la revisión la junta de
ejecutiva evaluó que las acciones
decisivas recientes fueron fundamentales
para estabilizar los mercados
restablecer la confianza y asegurar
objetivos cuantitativos clave incluido
el límite mínimo para las reservas
internacionales netas A fines de
septiembre y el límite máximo para el
financiamiento monetario del déficit
fiscal y en Brasil arrancó la campaña
hacia la segunda vuelta de las
elecciones presidenciales del 30 de
octubre una jornada en la que la firma
datafolla publicó un sondeo que da un
49% de intención de Voto anulada Silva
frente al 44 que obtiene Jair bolsonaro
ambos candidatos se lanzaron acusaciones
cruzadas Lula dijo que hay que poner al
frente del país a alguien que le guste
el pueblo o el sonar o por su parte
tildó de borracho y corrupto a Lula
hay que sacarlo de ahí y poner a alguien
que le gusta el pueblo y le gustan los
hombres las mujeres los niños y los
trabajadores
un abrazo compañeros y hasta la Victoria
Si Dios quiere
votar un gusto si pones a un borracho al
frente de Brasil un tipo sin
responsabilidades que tiene un historial
de corrupción un historial de
libertinaje hacia la familia brasileña
de ataques a sacerdotes y pastores de
ataques a las fuerzas armadas de ataques
a la policía crees que funcionará la
ciudad estadounidense de Nueva York que
decretó el estado de emergencia debido a
la gran cantidad de migrantes que llegan
diariamente desde los estados
fronterizos del sur el gobernador de
Texas uno de los que envía buses también
a Washington y Chicago dice que seguirán
mandando a estas personas hacia otras
ciudades y acusabaiden de la crisis
migratoria Andrés granadillo con los
detalles
estado de emergencia en Nueva York
decretó el alcalde Erick Adams a través
de una orden ejecutiva tras la llegada
masiva de migrantes desde la frontera
sur del país
esta orden ejecutiva ordenará
formalmente a todos los organismos
pertinentes que coordinen sus esfuerzos
para construir los centros de ayuda
humanitaria a la vez que suspenderá
ciertos requisitos de uso del suelo para
acelerar este proceso
la ciudad gastará mil millones de
dólares para gestionar la afluencia de
solicitantes de asilo desde principios
de septiembre han llegado entre 5 y 6
autobuses diarios a la ciudad pero este
jueves 9 unas 17.000 personas arribaron
a Nueva York desde abril para Adams esta
gran afluencia de migrantes abonda una
crisis ya existente
una ciudad que se recupera de una
pandemia mundial en cursos se ve
desbordada por la crisis humanitaria
hecha por manos humanas hemos recibido
parte de la ayuda que hemos solicitado
la hemos recibido pero necesitamos más
estamos al borde del precipicio
Texas enviado buses llenos de migrantes
hacia Washington Nueva York y Chicago
aún así el gobernador republicano de
Texas dice que seguirá haciéndolo
continuaremos transportando a los
migrantes a Nueva York DC Chicago para
aliviar a nuestras ciudades fronterizas
hasta que bailen haga su trabajo para
asegurar la frontera el gobernador de
Florida el republicano ron de santis
llevó recientemente en avión a un grupo
de unos 50 migrantes a la isla de
marta's binger en Massachusetts los
demócratas acusan a abot y a desantis de
utilizar a los migrantes como un arma
política
la tasa de desempleo en Estados Unidos
cayó en septiembre al 3,5% desde el 3,7
de agosto según el departamento de
trabajo que agregó que 5,8 millones de
personas están desocupadas las
estadísticas también muestran que en el
noveno mes del año los empleadores
agilizaron su nivel de contratación los
analistas consideran que el mercado
laboral sigue mostrando resistencia a la
subida de tasas de interés por parte de
la reserva Federal lo que podría
Conducir a que sigan aumentando en los
próximos meses El Banco Central ha
venido elevando tasas en un esfuerzo por
controlar la inflación pero con el
riesgo de llevar a la economía a una
recesión precisamente por este temor
Wall Street la principal bolsa
estadounidense cerró en rojo este
viernes con el nasdaq que aglutina a las
principales empresas de tecnología
cayendo un 3,8%
y cerramos en la isla chilena de rapa
nui comúnmente conocida como La isla de
Pascua hay un incendio causó graves
daños a los famosos moai en estas
estatuas gigantes sagradas para los
aborígenes de La Isla Se abrieron
grietas por el calor del fuego Pedro
edmunds alcalde de rapanui denunció que
los incendios que durante la semana han
arrasado más de 100 hectáreas son
consecuencia de la dejación del Estado
chileno para con la isla
hasta aquí este repaso informativo siga
conectados a France 24 y France 24.com
[Música]